good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy hump
yeah right yes wednesday hump day
wow thank you i know it's confusing is
it hum day is it not dude's not here
brew's not here you can't tell what day
it is but it is hump day for a moment i
thought it might be thursday yeah i'm
just all like confused because we
are doing four shows this week and it
just doesn't feel like a wednesday i
don't know i understand they say
mercury's
no they do say mercury's in retrospect
mercury mercury mercury
mercury mercury is in retrograde
i don't subscribe to me neither it's
just an excuse for bad behavior it's
just an excuse to be a mess yeah like oh
sorry mercury's in retrograde sorry i'm
late like clean your room no you're just
late
it's not mercury's fault so i don't
really believe in that chip but no get
your [ __ ] together maybe that's why we
can't decide what day it is no no we
decided like really quickly mercury was
no longer in the room yeah i'm just not
into all these horoscopes like oh i'm
such a sagittarius you know like no
you're just annoying what's
so funny is i was talking to my friends
about horoscopes and we were trying to
figure out what horoscope like the baby
will be and i was like well since it's a
boy it doesn't matter because she
doesn't give a [ __ ] no totally these
girly things and i just want to say like
if anybody ever comes up to me and it's
like oh my your baby's due in
june it's gonna be a gemini
leave my home no that's like what people
say it's like toxic it's when's your
baby do what's the gender
horoscope analysis i just don't believe
that and i know this is like hella
offensive i just feel like if you're
looking into your you know stars and
your moon charts like
you need to start doing other things
like if you're looking for like a
solution to your problem what you're
looking for it's not in your horoscope
no if you're looking for answers
in the horoscope
you need to go find the answers
elsewhere yeah i would agree sorry to
everyone that we're offending so early
in the morning you know what and so you
know early at the beginning of the show
yeah we're just you know feeling
offensive yesterday was the celiacs
today the horoscopes monday was the
celiac one day was a celiac did you
offend anyone yesterday i didn't see
anything
oh i guess technically like if you were
an angelina jolie stan who watched
yesterday's episode you wouldn't have
been too pleased with us
things happen you guys and the good
thing is that i don't think any of those
people exist so
i don't think so either i've not met one
um
okay so we have a great show for you
guys today it's wednesday vanderpump
rules premiered last night which was
like an outer body experience like
honestly so much time has passed yeah i
felt like i didn't even know these
people at all i have so many thoughts
it was a strange experience it was right
um so we'll be recapping that in the tv
recap and i watched the downton abbey
movie last night that i want to save for
the tv recap because i don't want to
spoil anything but i had a
an experience while watching it i'll say
that okay i'm really excited to hear
even though i know but like i'm excited
to to discuss also it's 10 45 do not let
me forget at 11 o'clock on the dot that
i have to order us lunch the place we
want opens and like
it's just important so yeah don't let me
forget we are recording another podcast
after this for our patreon channel so if
you guys remember a few weeks ago we had
a deer toasters um about a woman whose
husband was like always leaving a mess
around the house and it was really um
it was really upset traumatizing and it
sort of turned into this conversation
about things our husbands do that annoys
us and you guys were just like dying
over everything so we are doing a
patreon episode all about things our
husbands do that annoy us we got a lot
of submissions from you guys about
things your partners do and so we're
just gonna like swap stories yeah you
know what by the way i was shook because
like we wrote a prompt in our facebook
group like if you have a significant
other who does something [ __ ]
annoying like drop a comment first of
all 600 comments so far when i checked
this morning so i just love how we can
all
agree on that yeah and
when i was reading through i didn't want
to read through a lot because i really
want to be surprised when when we record
i had
i couldn't relate to some of these
people's problems at all like they're
definitely universal like significant
other
problems that everyone comes across like
dishes can you take the trash out i mean
now but then people were coming up with
some random [ __ ] that like their
boyfriend's girlfriend's husband's wives
do and i was like
can't relate yeah there was some stuff
that i was like oh i'm so glad that
that's like not something that i'm
dealing with but we're going to get
through it all and you know have a
little laugh
i left my house last night which was
just like i've got to stop doing that
you had a great time you do it all the
time i know but like a week nights are
supposed to be relaxing
like i feel like the way people treat
their weekends is how i treat my
weekdays like i recharge on the weekdays
like i work i feel productive i get my
manicures i watch tv and then the
weekend comes like
the weekdays are my break from the
weekends if that makes sense okay so
it's just been like you know everyone's
back in the city post summer post
covered like so many things going on
gotta catch up with so many peeps and
honestly i just can't do it anymore even
though i'm not saying i had an amazing
time i went to dinner with robbie bader
and we had the best time but like
i'm just exhausted today i'm exhausted
for you i know
gotta switch to a three-day weekend
yeah that would solve all the problems
i'm giving up hope on it no jackie you
can't i am b and i'm also not convinced
that that's the right way
to move forward as a society who are you
i don't know i just
it's five days for a reason you know no
i really think like if we switch to a
four day week three day weekend like so
many things would be different like i
just feel it i just feel like at least
right now we already don't have enough
structure
are you talking about me and you no no
as a society what do you mean like we
just don't have enough structure
everyone's working from home like the
weekdays bleed into the weekends you
know
and if we go to a 4-3 ratio that just
like would disintegrate further you
never know it maybe it could possibly
have an adverse effect like four days
we're out here we're killing it we're
making our coin we're getting things
done that's very popular that's very
possible because i'm just saying that's
a possibility yeah i mean i'm open to
whatever but i'm just
it's not as i just can't believe you're
saying this when literally one of the
founding principles of this show
is our belief in the four days i know
but it's like not as important to me as
it once was and as someone once pointed
out that a four-day work week starts
with four-day child care which means the
kids are only in school for four days a
week and i'm sorry they need that fifth
day no you know what they need that
fifth day i am like a firm believer in
education being a farce
oh i agree but they need to they need
like schooling they need day care no one
goes on at school no learning bullying i
just think schools are [ __ ] toxic
honestly and i cannot recall one thing
i've learned even if you decide to
homeschool there needs to be five days
of schooling i really can't recall one
thing i've learned past the age of like
fifth grade that i find valuable like
fifth grade up until then you learn how
to read write basic math like that
shit's important but like why was i
learning about like
i don't know like neutrons
when i've never used a neutron neutron
or a potent
proton in my life
like that seems like a waste of time to
me i don't know it's interesting to know
like what the world around you is made
up of yeah but so i still don't know
what it is but you do neutrons protons
atoms what are those
they're
things that
make up mass like is this a proton
no
it's not
is like that a proton
okay here's a better question this is
probably the dumbest conversation okay
where where are the atoms
they're in the atmosphere oh they're
like here atmosphere they're here
or is this made of atoms i don't i'm not
a scientist i can't tell you see that's
what i'm saying we spent all this time
on like protons and neutrons electrons
and we still don't know what the [ __ ] it
is you sound pretty well-versed
electrons
well so you know the protons are
positively charged look at her the
neutrons are neutrally charged electrons
negative look at you
yeah
now all i'm saying is like
the four day work week works and you
poking holes in it it's not the kind of
support we need on our side right now
i'm not i'm never gonna be like on the
other side of you know the picketing
saying i want a five-day work week yeah
you're gonna be on the other side of the
street saying i want a six day workout
no but i just don't know if i'm showing
up for the protest for four days oh i i
really believe that i no longer have a
horse in this race
that's disgusting honestly like
you live in like how could you do this
to me things change priorities change
well for those who still are championing
the four day work week i see you i
understand i'm like against the four day
work week it's just become less
important i've moved on and it's not
happening and so i need to move on i
actually just don't agree with that like
we are moving forward
okay um
i support your support for it it's
honestly disgusting that i'm so
supportive it's disgusting tacky
disgusting i'm sorry guys and there's
been a lot of studies that people like
four day work weeks can lead to more
productivity and if we go in four day
work week direction i will still be
thrilled
but i'm just moving on from it in terms
of like waiting for it it's like waiting
for rain waiting
and i just need to start
hoping for breathing on other things
yeah i feel that for sure that's really
what i meant i didn't mean anything to
vary okay by the way i 100 hear you
because it's never going to happen okay
thank you so like it's annoying but like
i still believe in it 100 as gu but like
the waiting is definitely becoming
annoying okay great glad i'm so glad we
like worked through that like we had a
low point with the protons and then we
got back
because
that was an important distinction yeah
you know that's all i meant like i
really wasn't trying like up in the
whole show
and say like i take back everything i
ever said yeah and just like
like take a dump on our core principles
and values yeah no no i wasn't trying to
take a dump on them by the way as much
as we say like the four day work week is
such an integral part of this business
we actually don't even have the four day
work week but to this week we do
this week we do this week we stand in
solidarity
yes we do so we have an amazing show as
usual and i just feel like it's time to
get into it there's some mindless news
there's from some mindful news yeah it's
a nice mix we love to see it and without
further ado
thinking of him on hump day it is time
for the fast-eye stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
brutal
bruce the best electric toothbrush on
the market not only does it work so
fabulously it is also very affordable
because a lot of electric toothbrushes
are out here charging over 200
which in my opinion is just unreasonable
and brush agrees and that's why they
have an affordable amazing
electric toothbrush that comes with six
unique modes to customize your brushing
experience the battery life lasts four
weeks and it comes with a magnetic
charging stand compact travel case and
they offer a subscription program so you
never have to forget to change your
brush head again because they will ship
you new replacement heads for your brush
every six months
they also offer a very sleek
modern modern aesthetically pleasing
design comes in trend driven colors i've
had two colors right now i have this
like hunter green moment and prior to
that i had like a millennial pink moment
they're constantly dropping new
colors it's literally supreme like
biggest drops you gotta get the colors
um and we have a 15 off discount for you
um so if you want to get 15 off your
brush toothbrush kit and the refill plan
use promo code toast at bruce.com that's
15 off using promo code toast at
b-r-u-u-s-h-dot-com
thank you claudia first it's a pleasure
story some big news jesse palmer has
been named the new host of the bachelor
he says i'm humbled by the opportunity
to return the bachelor has found its new
host jesse palmer will take the reins as
the 26th bachelor embarks on his journey
to find love abc announced yesterday the
former nfl quarterback is returning to
the franchise after becoming the fifth
bachelor in 2004. he ended his
relationship with jessica bolen but the
couple called it quits he ended his
season with jessica bowling but they
called it quits one month later he is
now engaged to model emily fardo who he
began dating in 2017. this isn't his
first time hosting for abc he previously
hosted the network's dating series the
proposal in 2018. oh my god right
as well as the ultimate surfer this
summer so this is really interesting let
me tell you why one because what i would
think like who eventually is going to
replace chris harrison jesse palmer
never crossed my mind when it's such an
obvious answer i'm like so shocked
because it's so obvious so if you don't
know jesse palmer is the host of daily
mail tv so he's actually like a
certified bonafide host a professional
host that's what you know that's on his
linkedin he's connected to the franchise
yes he's been the bachelor he's very
handsome like
and he was hosting these ancillary
series for abc how did we not think of
this no i can't believe it never crossed
my mind because it's so obvious yeah and
i feel like there's something really
interesting going on here because
there's like two in my opinion bachelor
nation is comprised of two people two
groups of people the first group is like
people who've been watching since day
one like we watched in high school like
have seen jesse palmer they were
obsessed with like
what's that bachelorette's name with the
d
diandra yeah like something like that
you know like they were just obsessed
from day one they like know and that
tends to be like an older crowd because
the show has been on for so long and
then the second group of people is
people who recently started watching
because all these contestants become
influencers
the snatcher yes
so the second group this gen z crew has
no [ __ ] idea who jesse palmer is like
i was reading our comments on instagram
like people were like
i'm sorry to this man who is this man
and then this like og bachelor nation
crew are obsessed like this is the best
thing that ever happened to them and
they're the people who feel like chris
harrison was so wronged and they want
him back and i think that this choice of
jessie palmer like really satiated this
group of people
i think that it has the potential to
satiate both groups of people i actually
am very curious to hear what the
snatcher thinks because i would say that
she's the spokesperson for group number
two yes of course and she's dropping her
new episode tomorrow so i'm sure we'll
get her thoughts on this and she
probably does not know who jesse palmer
is but i think that just his hosting
chops will speak for himself i think
that he's a good choice because he is a
host he will show up to the show and it
won't be about him and that's what it's
meant to be to be a host and so i
thought a lot of people wanted wells but
like wells then it's about wells you
know you know what i think wells could
have done like a similar job in not
making it about him about himself but if
i'm choosing between wells and jesse
palmer i'm going with jesse like this is
a more serious choice it's a serious job
like chris harrison took it very
seriously and it's the bachelor saying
like okay we are making changes but not
that many changes like
this is still it's not going to be you
know a rotating cast of former
bachelorette
exactly like it's still going to be the
show with the host and the contestants
as it should be in my opinion like as
much as i love like you know seeing all
these celebrities get involved in
bachelor in paradise it's very confusing
and the point of a host and what chris
harrison was very good at was being this
like
stable figure in the show i know a lot
of the like lead contestants relied on
him a lot like behind the scenes and you
could feel that he was this like
paternal energy and i definitely feel as
though that's missing
yeah like that stability and i think
tasha and caitlyn
did an amazing job but they are not
hosts they really were more there as
like friends they weren't like hosting
the show that's what they said too and
so i think that like if
this just signals that you know the
bachelor is going back to being the
bachelor and then the bachelor in
paradise is the fun one still so is
jessie palmer not hosting bachelor in
paradise i assume like it's a one one
man does the whole job i would think
he's doing bachelor in paradise but like
they do all these extracurricular things
on bathroom paradise whether it's even
with when chris harrison was the host
like they would bring in
all these different elements so
they're saying the bachelor will go back
to being the bachelor i just like feel
stupid for never once putting jessie
palmer's name into the ring like it's so
obvious beyond stupid we were just
talking about him because i said i see
him at the u.s open yeah and by the way
he's very handsome yeah no i think that
this is a really good choice i think he
is up to the task me too and
i look forward to seeing if i ever watch
again what he brings to the table do you
think that like when i was sitting next
to him at the us open like he knew he
was about to be the next best they do
things so fast at it
but like also
i he definitely had already received the
initial email of you know we'd like to
test you for initially
yeah you know like he knew his name was
in the ring yeah i wish he would have
told me like i feel when when i saw the
news i was like duh like it was i felt
so dumb especially since he hosted the
proposal and we've spoken about we
actually talk about him all the time
like no and
we're just
i think everybody missed it i because
everybody i think there were so many
predictions floating around and i
honestly never saw his name in the mix
not once if only it was this easy to do
uh wheel of uh jeopardy replacement
what happened with that what did they
end up doing they're still like rotating
figuring it out
they don't have a jessie palmer just
waiting no in the wings and that's that
sucks that doesn't that's tough oh it's
10 59. okay don't let me forget to order
we're ordering lunch because we need to
fuel up in between podcasts oh my god
wait hold on it's not 11 o'clock yet
just like won't let me add the salad on
the ice cream well then
what are we doing did you want a
fountain soda
i got you one
i'm good with water
thank you yeah yeah
yeah i'm going to swear fox unless it's
going to be burger king pound soda
because you can't have so much caffeine
when you're pregnant oh right and i
already do one espresso every day that
you're pregnant you really don't
complain as much as you should that
means a lot to me thank you maybe zach
would disagree no no no he really
wouldn't i just want to just you know be
the same girl i've always been
big belly yeah no you're just like you
know what you are you're the same girl
you've always been with just like a
little sprinkle of like a chessy energy
you
i didn't say you looked like jesse she's
like a very maternal figure and she does
like chili
and she makes it great okay and now it's
eleven o'clock okay so it's not
available right now okay give it a
minute okay yeah i quit the app just
sorry guys i guess i could share our
next story shortly you'll only be half
listening even though it's not really a
story more so a series of photos
and um
it's here what topping did you want a
peanut butter oreos
reese's or oreos yeah i found the oreos
first great okay and then the chopped
salad no chicken no chicken no roasted
peppers
okay
you can continue okay well the next door
is more so a series of photos and it
just um
i think it's it's it's an important
story okay should i get myself an ice
cream too yeah
we could split it we split last time
like i don't like
peanut butter
okay
just ignore me okay now i'm done let me
make sure i send it to the right address
because i'm always sending our work
lunch to my house
she is it's a scheme i do just so i
could have food in my house i don't have
to pay for
um
try it
by the way you guys if you are using
ubereats and you're not doing the
priority delivery for an extra 99 cents
like you ain't living this is not an ad
by the way this feels like a really
amazing
native ad for ubereats but no we're just
a couple of hungry gals expansive
okay you're gonna have to move faster
you can continue we're in the middle of
something
you can continue fine daniel craig and
stars hit the red carpet who's daniel
craig what is that james bond oh right
for no time to die world premiere
finally premiered this movie has been
just like
i would say the symbol of the
coronavirus pandemic why do you say that
because it was the first movie to be
pushed
due to covid i thought it was a quiet
place
that's how you that i remember that was
it for you but a quiet place at least
had their premiere
they're having their premiere now this
movie was supposed to come out in like
april i think and they pre-med they
pushed it early on they kept pushing it
now 18 months later it's finally here so
it's ever it's
and there was so much like the songs
already came out the movie hadn't come
out oh billy eilish did the song right i
listed this song so daniel craig and his
fellow stars finally hit the red carpet
and it was like it was a swanky affair
plus were will and kate at this affair
will kate and charles and camilla were
there charles and camilla yes and it was
a very much a royal affair and it also
took place at royal albert hall
so there was just interesting so much
happening like kate looked amazing
that's right that's amazing i feel like
the royal family hasn't had a royal
moment
in two years and
they're making up for it in spades this
was a gorgeous gown a gorgeous evening a
royal affair a royal affair and and i
think it's a sign you know i'm glad that
the movie's finally here how much longer
could they push it off right and
i'm happy for everyone about like anna
de armas is in it oh wow you know but
she was it was supposed to come out like
she was like peeking right do you ever
feel like there are certain people who
the covid ruin their career yeah i have
a few people i think and i think of anna
de armas like that like she was so hot
and heavy ben affleck coming off of
knives out like biggest model and um
actress in the world everyone wanted her
on their billboards everyone wanted her
in their movie and now i just like kind
of forgot about her
yeah but i think that you could say that
about anyone who was sort of popping off
at the time at that time but i think a
lot of people
made the most of it and
it didn't ruin their careers you know
yes but there's just a few people who
come to mind yes but i would have
thought that about like addison and
charlie
no because even though what they do is
digital but like they were just like
becoming big celebrities and then they
like missed a year and a half of like
real celebrity things like red carpet no
i totally disagree i think that like if
it weren't for covet i don't know if
they would have been as big of a stars
as they are now like people were just so
bored and ever like when they were
blowing up everyone's like i don't
understand why they're blowing up and
they were like i don't understand why
we're blowing up and it was literally
just because nobody had anything else to
do so i actually think like covid was
the catalyst for their fame and that's
what i think the way i remember it is
like they blew up right before covid but
i do think i guess everybody they went
from being like just tick-tock famous to
like now everybody's on tick-tock and
like them being a-list yeah
so i think but also their careers are
much more digital which works for
hillary and armas needs to wait for her
movies to come out right i don't even
think she has an instagram
i think she does she just gives me the
vibe that like she would not want it i
most like movie stars don't so there's
this netflix movie coming out like with
everyone you know jonah hill jennifer
lawrence
leonardo dicaprio have you seen the
trailer i've heard i think i heard about
jennifer lawrence and leo i think we
should just all talk about how the movie
looks atrocious like meryl streep is in
it i watch a trailer like
leo and jennifer lawrence are like these
nerdy scientists who like have to alert
the president that there's like an
asteroid coming and like meryl streep
the president like doesn't want to
believe it it looks so stupid like i was
actually really surprised are you gonna
watch it like probably what else am i
doing okay i finished downton abbey now
i have no will to live will you see
james bond no time to die i've only i
don't really get into the bond movies
um it's star-studded yeah i know i've
seen the one that adele i've seen 007
casino royale that one was good
and then adele wrote the song for
skyfall but i don't think i saw it i
don't think i've seen one of them not
one they're really not frozen you see
also daniel craig was like under fire
because he like someone had asked him
like you know eventually he's not gonna
be able to be bond anymore and people i
think this is his last bond they say
that every time no i think this is
really his last bomb but they haven't
and there it's going to be a while
before we get our new bond right and so
there are always these classic names
thrown in the ring like idris elba but i
someone had asked him like if you know
what would he think about a mrs like a
jamie bond you know
and he like went off being like no
and honestly like i kind of feel that
like
just making okay like just make another
movie with like a female spy like this
is james bond like
jane it's like
like leave it alone you know
i
hear you jamae
unless you may bond and she fights crime
in australia unless it's jamai bond i
don't want it and kwame is her sidekick
by the way i could literally
talk for hours just about jamae no i
agree and that's the only way we were
getting a female bond and by the way
like
you know when like you discover
something early or like you
yeah like you discover like a tv show or
an artist early like you feel really
proud so jamae is
an australian show she's a private
school girl that is such a good point
she is a private school girl
and jamae was a show in australia and i
think they took the first season of
jamae and played it on prime time on hbo
for one season and nobody watched it in
america but i did and like i feel like
i'm an investor in jamae like i feel
like i invented her i'm i
dressed up as jamae that's my favorite
story about claudia so jamae premiered
and no she was a character on summer
high tie and then she yeah she got her
spin off so people were familiar with
jamae but it's definitely extremely
niche there especially in america she's
huge in australia so for halloween 2014
claudia dressed up as jamae private
school girl and we went to a party by
the way it was a good costume right like
just execution-wise
yeah yeah i looked like jamae yeah you
were wearing like the school uniform
uniform and you have the same hair color
and and i did a side part and i just
walked around i was like you're such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] right but like nobody
[ __ ] knew what claudia was it just
looked like she was wearing a nightgown
honestly it was honestly embarrassing
especially because the party we went to
like i was an intern and jackie was a
full-time employee at work it was a work
event event yeah and nobody knew that
was never that was like yeah that's the
worst thing that could happen with your
costume especially if like you're you
committed to a look that like you're not
feeling yourself yeah i felt that way
when ben and i dressed up as dj khaled
and his son
and like nobody knew who we were and it
was just like stupid yeah that sounds
stupid we were just like trying to be
like viral because like dj khaled was
like 2017. like dj khaled was like
yeah snapchat king
in hindsight that sounds like not a good
idea they can't all be winners i'm sorry
like we've had some when we dressed up
as dr phil and danielle bregoli that was
fabulous except like i went to a party
and someone else was dressed up as
teenagoly and like she did it better but
whatever as a unit me she didn't have a
boyfriend so like me and ben were
perfect together and then we also did
blac chyna and rob which i think is our
best work that's good what about you
what's your best halloween costume moira
uh what would you say moira moira was
really good honestly
no offense like i crush it on with
halloween it's been a while and like
i've lost some steam because also i have
nowhere to go usually and by the way
halloween this past year i was invited
to a party and zach and i were like
we'll go so that we can dress up and we
just wound up dressing up taking
pictures and then kayla came over and
that was that sounds so funny that was
enough for me by the way i'm seeing
kayla literally in like 30 hours i know
my best costume so where do i begin i
mean someone reminded me yesterday not
including this no not these are the best
ones of course they're a whole
performance and we are working on
something
so good for this year we are and we're
going to vlog it so you guys can like
get through the pro let's understand the
process and our thought process so
someone reminded me yesterday angelina
jolie plays maleficent that's why you
think she's a witch yes and i once
dressed as maleficent crushed it that
was really good um once dressed as
chanel from scream queens cute crushed
it
once dressed as a cheerio from glee
oh that was your best in my opinion so
cute um
i have to go through my timeline but i
used to really get into it i used to go
hard oh riverdale
and i like just a shower blossom and and
zach was um oh that's cute zach and i
also did um jesse and woody from toy
story it's a little basic but it was a
good execution i was feeling my look by
the way honestly
it's so much easier to put together like
a fire costume when you have a husband
or a boyfriend like to play along with
you he was a
dallas cowboys football player i was
dallas cowboys cheerleader
that was really really cute very casey
musk graves yeah
so yes
i like how we've just taken this whole
james bond jamae halloween but yes
justice for jimmy bond
justice for jamai bond and justice
for our next sponsor honey when you shop
like usual on your favorite sites honey
will automatically fill in the promo
code box for you at checkout but it
won't fill it in with just one code
it'll dump a ton of codes in there every
code it can find then they test them in
seconds to see if one gives you a
discount plus honey knows where to look
for promo codes that are hard to find on
your own it's like getting a million
promo codes from this one little podcast
ad so if you don't have honey it is the
best browser extension if you use this
link it'll be completely free to
download and basically every time you're
shopping i've used it on clothes i've
used it on food i've used it on makeup
every time you're shopping this little
box comes down and you like press the
button yeah apply coupons and it takes
like four seconds and it'll run every
coupon out there on the internet and
find you the one with the best savings
i'm always just like constantly saving
money it's so hard to be made
um you can join honey and get the
browser extension at joinhoney.com toast
that's joinhoney.comtoast
and you truly just won't regret it no
you will not save money with honey every
time i'm shopping there
it's just a part of who i am coming in
clutch with some savings i shaved on
this shirt in particular oh wow
just i mean obviously so that you can
make fun of me i bought this sweater
online and like i probably saved money
on it too yeah because honey's just
looking out for you even when you're not
looking out for yourself
constantly
okay next story a little
sad relationship news srn
vicki gumbelson and steve lodge break up
after two-year engagement yeah the
former real housewives of orange county
star and lodge have broken up after two
years two years after getting engaged a
source confirmed to page six e news
first reported that the gubernatorial
hopeful ultimately ended things with
vicky after they tried reconciling
following a june split that gumbelson
had initiated i had no idea there was
such turmoil here i really thought they
were a steady couple i just saw like
yesterday that they had unfollowed each
other on instagram so i knew it was over
and i totally forgot steve was a
gubernatorial candidate and i wonder how
it's going to affect his gubernatorial
race but it doesn't happen
oh
i guess it really affected it then they
stayed together for the race and that
she could be like the ghost lady
and like maybe that would be enough to
keep them happy and then when he lost
like she knew like i'm married to a
loser
and like i went out i sometimes feel
like
don
dunville like was the one for vicki and
i know he was like mean and angry
but i don't know i just feel like they
could have
somehow made it work i think that's like
with anything you know
they could have made it work but they
didn't want to put in the work that it
would take that sounds like a lot of
work for them or honestly maybe brooks
was the guy for her stop talk about
having like the worst track record of
relationships of all time
yes but this relationship
i thought it was different you know
uh oh she's a restaurant calling okay
just pick up okay hold on make sure our
order is snatched to the gods
anyways
oh an insider told e news that stephen
vicki had been living separately for
much of the pandemic and that steve had
been living like he was a single man in
puerto vallarta while vicki was still in
the u.s yeah that doesn't make for a
good you know
engagement on your salad no no
other than salad tings
thank you for calling
obviously your order was problematic
obviously like you didn't like clarify
with that no she's just confused because
like like why would you pay for a big
old salad when you like took off all the
good things when i took off the protein
yeah exactly usually i would get a scoop
and she was trying to be nice because
like you're paying for it like why don't
you get something else okay usually i
would get a scoop of tuna but sometimes
they put it on top of the salad and then
in transit it just becomes like no tuna
doesn't travel well and like i'm not
technically supposed to eat tuna while
pregnant but i had it once and i would
have it again if it was good quality
tuna they also have egg salad
but on a salad i guess that's gross i
actually like egg salad do you want to
call it no no no no no no no i'm not in
the mood right it's too early it's not
even noon so that's why i don't want
tuna right i understand if we were
eating at the restaurant i would have
gotten it of course that's right change
at the restaurant things change but you
have to think of the transport you know
what i wanted to tell her
because i love this place but they do
one thing that really bothers me
especially in transit but also in the
restaurant so i always get a wrap and
they put the wrap in like the plastic
container with a pickle and so when you
open it up like the pickle is just like
fragrant everywhere and your whole wrap
smells like pickle like the juice of the
pickle contaminated it is [ __ ] i should
have said no pickle damn
or pickle on the side so you could eat
it yeah i'm sorry that's annoying
our next story khloe kardashian responds
to fan asking if she was banned from the
met gala
what did she say she said that is
absolutely not true
on tuesday a fan asked the good american
founder to clarify speculation that she
hasn't been asked to attend there had
also been gossip circling that chloe had
been banned from the event apparently e
news reported that i did not hear that
me neither so the fan wrote chloe now
that you're online please tell of the
met gala rumors are true because i'll
burn that dinosaur's bones khloe
kardashian please clarify thank you to
which she responded absolutely not true
i mean i don't think you can be banned
from an event if you've never been
invited right so i just think she's
never been invited no and honestly like
we were just talking about this and like
how she's like maybe just not high brow
enough and ever since we started having
those conversations she's been on this
like national campaign of a candy crush
commercial yes and it's like so
embarrassing i mean sure she's making a
lot of money but like you just can't you
can't do both i agree but she was in one
of the commercials with jojo cat did you
see that one and they were so cute and i
was thoroughly enjoyed it i know but
like jojo cat is like having this moment
right now first of all she's on every
billboard like she's a new face of pepsi
yeah she has this
she's always just like
i don't know when she does it it's not
like tacky at all like she's just right
now like one of the famous famous female
artists in the world and like when you
do that you become
a spokesperson for a lot of brands like
for me it doesn't feel weird like when
chloe does it it's just like oh god like
what is chloe doing again i don't know
why i think it's just like being like
mean and and having different standards
for different people i'm just like being
honest i don't think i mean no i i hear
what you're saying i do
like doji cat is just like so like
millennial i don't know i know i hear
what you're saying when she does a candy
crush question
she should have been at the mat gala i
agree and that was someone who i was
surprised wasn't there agreed um so i
don't think that candy crush and met
gala invitations like are mutually
exclusive
though i think for khloe kardashian they
are
no but she didn't even answer the
question
so she said she's not banned but did she
say she's never been invited she no she
just said she's not banned right no i'm
like
the band is like not the real news story
you can't what would she be banned for
like that's stupid she didn't answer the
part of the question that i really want
to know like have you ever been invited
if so like how does that make you feel
the fan didn't ask that question they
just said is it true that you've been
banned
oh that's like so embarrassing for chloe
i know but at least courtney didn't go
this time and kylie
yeah no but kylie's been like you know
what life has never been so courtney
goes then chloe's the only kardashian
who's never this year those who didn't
go were in the majority yes yes no but
i'm just saying like
of in the lifetime like kylie's been a
million times she'll go a million times
same with kendall same with kim but
chloe and courtney have never been and
so when courtney was in the city for the
vmas i'm like oh her and travis are
definitely going and that would have
been really sad for chloe but now it's
still chloe and courtney like it's still
not that sad because both of them have
still never been but once one of them
goes and leaves the other like then it's
sad maybe they made a pact to each other
like we'll never embarrass the other
like that right it'll be both of us or
none of us yeah and anna would be smart
and especially after you know the motley
crew we saw this year woof who are you
to not invite chloe i completely agree
are you ready for our fifth and final
story already i know it happened so fast
is it the fifth and final story that's
brought to you by pill club it is
because life is stressful enough and
access to health care shouldn't be
luckily getting birth control is one
less thing you have to worry about with
the pill club you'll never have to make
a trip to the doctor or wait in line at
the pharmacy ever again because they
provide access
to care from the comfort of your own
home and delivery to your door in very
discreet packaging
so the pill club is a birth control
subscription prescribed by medical
professionals and delivered straight to
your door for free the pill club carries
over 120 fda approved brands and most
brands of birth control are free with
insurance or medicaid otherwise prices
start as low as just nine dollars a
month without insurance they'll deliver
the birth control to your door in for
free and discreet packaging and right
now when you go to the pillclub.com
toast the pill club is offering a 10
donation to bedsider.org for every
morning toast listener who becomes a
patient your donation will help
low-income individuals get access to
birth control through bedsider.org so
that's
thepillclub.comtoast to get your first
birth control care package and donate to
help more women in need of affordable
birth control remember that's
thepillclub.com
toast and you must use that link to make
a donation thepilclub.com
toast thank you claudia it's a pleasure
our fifth and final story is that laurie
lachlan has set her acting return in
when hope calls at gac family so she is
actually headed back to hallmark
with a guest starring role in season two
of when hope calls at gac family let me
explain first
lachlan will reprise the role of abigail
stanton pronounced her name so weird
even though i know it's like the right
way it's lori laughlin but continue
laurie will reprise the role of abigail
stanton whom she originally played in
when calls the heart on the hallmark
channel when hope calls is a spin-off
series of that series it's first she was
also on when calls the heart
okay
this is a lot of when calls to
understand yeah right
she was on one co calls the heart which
is the big show which is a big show on
harmony she played abigail stanton oh
her character is going to another show
so when calls the heart the big show got
a spin-off of when home call when hope
calls that is on like a different
hallmark affiliated platform the
spin-off started without laurie and now
she's joining the sparrow spin-off in
her when calls the heart roll okay okay
okay um
it's first season aired on hallmark
movies now in hallmark channel but it's
moving to gac family for season two i'm
not sure what gac family is but i'm sure
i'll be downloading it um at the holiday
season this is very interesting because
i remember when we were talking about
the college admission scandal like
in its heyday
we were talking about felicity huffman
versus laurie laughlin and how like we
think it'll have a much bigger effect on
lori laflin's career because laurie does
home and family it's constantly hallmark
lifetime like very homey family-friendly
stuff and that is very hard to get back
into when you've been through a scandal
um but she's out here working before
felicity huffman is even so felicia
huffman's working i thought some stuff i
don't know let's check her imdb i feel
like i've seen her like
commercialization she's like i haven't
heard a word from her since she's got
out of prison no i think i saw a
commercial like first a big show or a
movie really yeah
yeah hold on well i just want to say i
believe like if you do your crime you do
your time you should be able to
earn a living earn a living so
i agree i think that i don't have a
problem with this i don't have a problem
with this either and i think
i i think for hallmark like starting her
on this secondary show seeing how you
know the fans react maybe they really
missed her right i think it all sounds
good also the description for the show
sounds
like a very little house on the prairie
right listen to this the series is set
in brookfield a town on the western
prairie of cat canada what did i say in
season two a christmas festival worthy
of harper's bazaar happens in brookfield
as is this modern times
no because i've seen they're always
wearing like bonnets like yeah no
happens in brookfield as the community
is one of three contenders in the
magazine search for america's number one
cris country christmas town the entire
town is preoccupied with creating the
essence of christmas for the
photojournalist's lens though behind the
scenes residents are not living the
spirit of the season
in the midst of the fuss a stagecoach
appears and outsteps abigail stanton and
her son cody who have brought a troubled
boy to lillian's orphanage wow chilling
chilling stuff so and you know olivia
jade is back at work now she's done
dancing with the stars like i do feel
like everyone from this scandal is like
slowly moving out of it but i'm
constantly like reading things on
twitter like
you know seeing what people are saying
and everyone's like can't believe like
olivia jade like
honestly i just think it's really
important to remember that like nobody
in this college admission scandal like
murdered anyone like the way that like
we want them all to like go in a hole
and like never come out like
they made a judgment error and they
broke the law they paid for their crimes
can we move on yeah i think they didn't
even hurt anyone like they didn't kill
anyone yeah
like a narrative on social media no i
agree i mean don't go to social media
for for their thoughts but
also watching the documentary i think it
was called the college admission scandal
varsity blues the one that was like a
dramatization a dramatization so bizarre
i sort of changed my pov about the whole
thing because yeah the most famous
people were like the face of the scandal
when like just these like not famous
super rich people were the ones doing
way worse things spending more money
bribing people breaking more laws that
wasn't even what i was taking away from
it which was just that the [ __ ] up
nature of the college admissions process
to begin with yes
it shouldn't be that there are all of
these back doors but the side door is
illegal yeah um and it's just corrupt
through and through total and then all
of that corruption landed on the
shoulders of olivia jade right and like
all that corruption quote unquote
victimized stanford or whatever school
it was that they were the victims of a
racketeering channel and they're a
billion dollar school and they were you
know the victims who accidentally bribed
seven hundred thousand dollars like what
did you do with that money yeah i agree
like it wasn't exactly what it was made
out to be in the press like once you
watched documentaries it was in the
press like it was what it was but i
think
the way we first looked at it
i just looked at it differently after
getting the whole picture of like what
other people do to get into college like
and by the way the weirdest thing is
that that guy what was his name the guy
who did it rick
rick singer he's still like not in jail
he's like chilling right because he sang
for his supper right
it's all so crazy anyways back to
felicity hoffman her last thing that
came out was in 2019 that's when the
college admission scandal happened and
she's in pre-production on the tv series
okay got it so she hasn't been in
anything since then you are correct so
lori is out here making money moves on
the hallmark channel on the homework
channel
um well that's a great segue into our tv
recap segment because vanderpump rules
was on last night but before we dive
into that can i please tell you about
the downton abbey movie i mean i already
told you but for the podcast yes so you
had told me you have such bad heartburn
like i have literally okay oh you got
them no sorry i have times in my other
purse
my big one i'm really sorry um it's okay
i usually just suffer through it but i i
feel like a fire breathing dragon like
does what is water supposed to help
heartburn i don't think it does anything
i always feel like it's extinguishing
the fire in my chest that's that's how
it feels the heartburn is so crazy so
sorry it's worse at night but now it's
like coming to me during the show
tums here
i always have a roll on me i'm so sorry
no it's not your fault i'll run out
after this and get you i don't like love
to take the tums because i feel like
they'll stop working if i take them like
twice a day you just take the tums like
trust me have you ever met ben software
he's been taking four times a day since
he was born and he's fine and he still
thinks they work like you're fine okay
fine um okay so the downton abbey movie
like you had put in like a really kind
of toxic
negative review yeah so what did you
think of it my
thought was it was so good to see the
gang back together i hadn't seen them in
months because i waited i was saving the
movie for a special time i only waited
two days i wish i watched it immediately
after when i was missing downton because
i would have appreciated more so i was
glad to see everyone back downton
setting i love that it had this royal
yes um theme
but i thought the premise was just i
thought it was silly i thought
everything was silly i thought that this
idea that the competing households and
they're like fighting over you know
who's gonna do what and it's like it
felt like um camp color war you know and
i just felt like it was silly so that
part was stupid and honestly i was
really surprised that anna misses baits
like for her terrible judgment in the
movie like oh we're having the distinct
honor of having the royal king and queen
here let's throw a prank and lock
everyone in their rooms anna is more
sensible than that so i was really so
much sabotaged same with carson like
they are so sensible and they are such
monarchists like
in actuality like i know their
characters so well their characters
would have never like pulled the wool
over the royal staff like yes it was
annoying that they didn't get to cook
and serve for the royal family but like
they would never have acted like such
buffoons yeah and they would never would
have disrespected the process like that
no because they are like so respectful
of the king and queen so they wouldn't
be respectful of even like
of service like carson wouldn't let
someone serve the sun right the footmen
in the in the dining room like and but
you're gonna usurp the royal household
but i'm sorry like the best part of the
movie
was when like you know they steal the
thunder from the royal service it goes
off without a hitch and of course nobody
at the meal
knows the difference is noticing that
this is mrs patmore's cooking and these
footmen aren't royal like they're just
talking to each other they're not even
looking at the staff
and mr mosley like puts his foot in it
and he's like actually this was the
staff at downton abbey mrs patmore
cooked and like it was he was like so
proud and as he's speaking he's
realizing he should shut the [ __ ] up
yeah i swear to god that was the best
part of the whole movie but there were
some things like i wanted to move
forward with like
obviously mr mosley really likes
baxter
and like they didn't even take back any
mean things you said about baxter
what did i say you called her a wedge
i'm sorry when she arrived she had major
wedgie vibes but i do believe people can
change and baxter is one of them i don't
take back she was [ __ ] wenchy as hell
working for thomas and you know what i
really do appreciate the character arc
of thomas like i used to like literally
beg for him to be fired just like get
him off the show but you know what he
was he's such a troubled soul like it's
so hard to be gay in those times and
like he just knew what he was and he
couldn't be himself and i don't know i
forgave him i did oh me too and honestly
what he ended up doing like over the
course of the show just like being a
menace was never nearly as bad as what
o'brien did
oh brian her lady ship soap o'brien had
to go if one of if i had to choose one
of them okay i think i i don't i don't
i do not detect a lie there so then
there were like just like other things
and first of all like one of the biggest
flaws in downton abbey period
from start to finish is their energy for
daisy
like why of so many people it's such an
ensemble cast so many people from the
downstairs servant's hall to the
upstairs the royals so many people have
come and go one of my favorites rose who
was played by lily james like and you
really and i didn't talk about the
character arc i loved her mostly because
she married you and like honestly i'm
just like worried about her in the
second movie because like we're slowly
approaching the holocaust cinema but she
lives in america
she's an embarrassment she'll be okay
okay thank god yeah we're slowly
approaching the hot cost and you know
that like marriage i feel like they're
literally
at the the end of the last couple
seasons and then with the movie they
slowed time down just so they don't have
to like talk about the holocaust i know
and also like mary's son is going to go
to war
in world war ii in world war ii and like
that's like it's like this period so the
movie's 1927 and it's like this in
between it's just like knowing what's
waiting 10 in 10 years like not good
so
the daisy of it all so many characters
have come and gone ones we loved ones we
didn't love and the fact that they just
decided from day one that daisy was
going to be like an important character
her relationships her attitude her
career was such a mistake first of all
she's the most annoying character i
[ __ ] hate her and the only thing
going for her is like mr mason and his
farm and she just like should [ __ ]
move there already especially because
her new boyfriend andrew loves the farm
and wants to help out with mr mason so i
thought when the movie came back that
daisy mr mason and andrew would all be
living at the farm and they weren't like
she hasn't evolved in her career at all
no and she calls herself a career woman
no and she's obsessed with like
forwarding and making a life for herself
and what has she done in the last she's
what how long does the show last for
it ends at 1927. does it start at 1917
no it started titanic which is 1912. 15
years daisy has not made wait that can't
be right i'm sorry right no but like
daisy she didn't age 15 years
yeah i mean
titanic happened
i'm so sorry i just need to like confirm
this
1912. so yeah it's 15 years that's a
major plot hole that from the beginning
to the end it's 15 years especially
because nobody really ages like not at
all so 15 years and the only thing she's
done is got an assistant from kitchen
maid to kitchen assistant like and she's
supposedly like this career woman so she
was the worst part of the movie hands
[ __ ] down
um but all other than that like i just
loved it and i couldn't believe how
there were so many negative reviews for
the movie like i thought the movie was
amazing i loved seeing the game back
together it was beautifully done i loved
the plot of the royals coming i thought
that was just such an interesting way of
doing it everyone was there branson the
assassination attempt like i thought it
was gorgeous i like the royals being
there i just needed to confirm that it
was 15 years because this hasn't dawned
on me yet and yes it was 1927 is the
movie
1912 is the titanic 15 years okay that's
like it's crazily an issue and there's a
second movie coming out this christmas
oh and then obviously the saddest part
spoiler alert i'll give everyone a
second oh my god is that obviously
maggie smith is probably not going to be
in the next movie because at the end of
the first movie she tells
mary that she's dying and honestly i
started
hysterically crying on the couch like i
was just so upset and you know what like
it won't be the same without her no she
has this joadave that i do feel like was
kind of toned down in the film like she
is getting older she can't constantly be
bringing the zingers as much as she used
to she like
all these people want to act to fool
like she's been telling me for 15 years
how to act if you didn't hear her that's
on you no and honestly like this whole
like cycle that basically mary is going
to be the next
maggie smith like it's so true first of
all like and second of all like mary is
so [ __ ] and like she is the next dad
with you i was just like crying on my
couch like it was beautiful you know
mary is the future of the family yes of
downton especially because her son will
inherit but
the passing of the torch was quite
beautiful it was chilling and i just
thought it was an excellent movie and i
loved it so much i'm so glad that i
can't wait for the second one i can't
wait for this except no maggie smith
probably and we are having
what's that guy's name
the affair
no he's in it dominic west dominic west
is in it
how do you know that because i saw a
trailer for see the next one and it said
dominic west i swear oh i'm going to
jump i'm like i i don't know why i'm
questioning everything that i've like
once knew today and no you are like
don't be so scared no but it's like if i
say something i need to make sure that
it was the correct thing you'll be so
insecure
okay
dominic quest imdb downton abbey a new
era
in prose productions who do you think he
plays
oh i'm sorry it comes out in 2022. why
do i keep saying this christmas
oh you're kidding that's wrong
that's just all wrong so do you think
that you are gonna go continue on this
you know
historical period journey no
i don't think so okay
i mean i watch the crown in downton
abbey like if i'm not a learned
individual then who is all right
speaking of learning the individual
let's talk about vanderpump rules which
is brought to you by liquid iv cooler
weather makes it easier to miss signs of
dehydration like overheating or
perspiration which means it's even more
important to keep your body properly
hydrated and with flu season being in
full swing proper hydration and vitamins
can help support a strong immune system
and liquid iv is here to hydrate you
faster and more efficiently than water
alone the liquid iv packs contain five
essential vitamins it has more vitamin c
than an orange and as much potassium as
a banana it's also healthier than sugary
sports drinks because they have no
artificial flavors preservatives and
they have less sugar than an apple
they're made with clean greek clean
ingredients and the liquid iv packets
are so effective they're also on a
mission to change the world because the
company is donating 4 million servings
in response to cobia 19 and the products
are being donated to hospitals first
responders food banks veterans and
active military also liquid iv is great
for hydration but it's also great for a
hangover yeah grab your favorite liquid
iv flavors nationwide at walmart or you
can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com
use the code toasta check out that's 25
off anything you order when you get
better hydration today using promo code
toast at liquidity.com
thank you claudia also liquid iv the
perfect sponsor for vanderpump rules
so many thoughts wait sorry oh yes it
would be sorry i wasn't saying yes nope
and perfect sponsor like for talking
about vanderpump rules my first thought
is just a general thought of like last
night's episode felt like intro to
reality television like at one point
sheena was like ariana likes
lala's here are you guys gonna duke it
out it's not like a pilot for a show i
don't wanna watch it it felt very
different like aside from the obvious
which is that
most of the most
favorite and interesting characters are
gone britney jacks stassi kristin
is that it
bret and max we don't count them
and they're really like the core of this
group of friends
that's the obvious part actually the
people whose absence i felt the most was
brittany and jackson i completely agree
they would have been at that party 100
kristin was always not invited and sassy
was always doing her own thing so but
like what's britney and jax's take on
you know
sandy schwartz okay so that's the
there's a couple things to unpack
it's obviously becoming and in addition
to what you said like it is like a
different editing like it all feels very
well and maybe they're all rusty because
like they haven't done the job in two
years and they also feel like they have
something to prove because they lost so
many fan favorites
but
it's just the way that they were talking
like felt really like a pilot episode
and it's obviously becoming clear that
this is like the tom and tom show and
tom and tom were on watchtraps live and
if that's the case thank you so much i'm
not interested i have to leave i cannot
listen to saham sandoval honestly i
can't stand either of them because you
know what if tom schwartz was my husband
i'd smack him upside the head he has no
[ __ ] respect for katie and the way he
never defends katie and is always like
let me handle this and like talk [ __ ]
about katie to sandoval i would kill him
like that's the worst type of husband i
know and then tom sandoval thinks that
he's literally the greatest artist who
ever lived and everything he does is so
great and everything he touches is so
great i can't stand him i can't stand
him like i don't find humor in anything
he says or does it feels so put on
the thing with schwartz and katie it's
like it must be like this
achilles heel in their relationship
which is that like yeah
he has a best friend who like is not
nice to her and he should be able to put
his foot down but it's also the thing
that's really making him a success tom
tom right and all these other ventures
like him and tom together are just these
big stars and what can you do and by the
way schwartz and sandy's is such a bad
name like it's maybe the worst i've ever
heard if they were serving matzo ball
soup and canisius she was totally right
and you know what like if they wanted to
use their name like
schwandy's like i don't know something
more
better like yeah they're definitely in a
tough spot and i'm in thinking about
this is alicia invited in this
restaurant she's not in this room she's
not that's why it's not called tom tom
got it
i mean what would be best for them is to
license the name from her because
like franchises they need it to include
their names their first names are the
same and those are taken they only have
their last names to work with
because that's what brings people it's
not because they're great restaurant
tours no but i also am worried about
this new restaurant because
i think we're past the peak of
vanderpump rules i think of course she's
spending all this money spending all
this money though i do think they're
always going to be like bachelorette
parties and people who are huge fans of
the show that when they go to la they
want that vanderpump rose experience but
there is sir there is pump there is tom
tom and yes the new one leblanc the new
one will
be you know exciting for a moment but
like i don't know that they have what it
takes like that is opening a restaurant
and operating restaurants
are so expensive costly endeavors it's
really hard to be profitable as a
restaurant and doing it with lisa is
like so low risk yes they didn't have to
put in a lot of money and lisa knows
exactly how to run and operate a
restaurant and i think them opening
another restaurant is a huge mistake
i think so too especially in la i mean
i'm sure the way that they look at it is
like they probably
got a little screwed with tom tom it's
much it but lisa did all the work and
they are each five percent correct yeah
so they probably are like we want more
this is what we should be doing we
should be opening restaurants and then
there should be a tom tom in new york
miami chicago like
we could franchise it you know
i would say that they should do that
with lisa but they're not going to do
that at 10
no
but i do think that they should
they should find a way to all work
together because
i don't know that they'll be able to
pull it off and also like i'm not
interested in trying to watch them do it
like no because tom sandoval just
steamrolls over time schwartz and i
would feel bad for him if tom schwartz
wasn't such a wussy like grow up like
it's just your friend and you know what
like protect your wife the way that he
talks about katie bothers me so [ __ ]
much especially now because i was
thinking i'm like
i didn't know that they were trying to
have a baby and now i'm just like you
know it might not be working out the way
that they want them to katie wants to be
involved in the restaurant
just [ __ ] let her like yeah tom
sandoval's such an ass no but also
they're so
dumb because one katie does have like
over a decade of restaurant experience
and two the more cast members involved
in the restaurant the more appealing it
is to fans of the show so if you involve
katie and ariana like that first of all
and it's the four of you like that opens
up new name ideas
they're just like
they they're so small-minded and like
they just don't have and they really
think and it's so crazy because tom
never even worked for lisa and she gave
him this opportunity on a golden platter
about that one they really believe that
they deserve it more than anyone else
but like not more than anyone more than
katie more than arya no and so now that
it's like the tom tom show i just think
like sandoval specifically is
even more in belief that like this was
always his show this was always how it
was meant to be like i am the star i
deserve this i got the restaurant i'm
opening another one and honestly it's
really not interesting to watch because
it's only him and katie
who are the last remaining ogs who were
full time from day one and by the way
she doesn't i'm like she's growing on me
first of all i love that she's just like
living her life like
she was wearing this pink dress because
that's all that fits her right now and i
just feel like sheena's always been very
uptight
very like
like inauthentic in a way and i don't
know what you feel like motherhood is
actually really really good for her and
i'm kind of like obsessed i i agree but
i think she'll always be sheena which of
course always count on but i agree i
think motherhood looks great on her yep
and i'm happy for her with brock i mean
obviously there's going to be some stuff
about brock and he does seem like a
little bit of an operator yeah he has
like four kids that he doesn't talk to
two kids he has two kids but he hasn't
talked to him in four years i think
thank you thank you um
and so yes that does you know raise
questions but there is a lid for every
pod and
if there is some funny stuff about him
like there's funny stuff about her too
yeah you know
i mean also like the fact that like you
know he's now in the promos like he oh
my god he was in the theme song he is a
full-time cast member like he met this
woman and said i'll join your job yeah
um which is like
good for sheena and her
work work schedule but it's weird for a
relationship you always you know you you
want someone who's like
supports you but it's not like it's that
supportive that you know
by the way exactly so next week except i
think i think beau eventually was on the
cast yeah
but not the first time we met him like
no but also so much time has passed
since they were last night that's true
their parents together they're all just
like that we had to catch up with them
so much like i had a baby i wrote a book
like i did a million things because it's
been two years since we last heard from
them also they go to palm springs next
weekend is that where racquel and james
get engaged i believe rochella roxella
right but
yeah rochella but i don't think they get
engaged next week no since they have a
fashion show they just need to wait time
yeah um and then the other thing was max
and james which like i was just
hysterically laughing at because the
fact that all of this fight fighting was
over the fact that like max told james
that they charged ten dollars at
dantanas to split a salad onto two
plates so moronic so moronic how is lisa
gonna let this boy talk to her son like
that i know what is with everyone on the
show and not defending their family i
have no idea but like if you sent a
series of texts calling my son a fat
prick oh you're you're not coming to my
house and you're certainly not working
for me no no no
this is just like kind of like when when
james sits down at sir with lisa and
it's like i'd love to come dj boy you
again i'm like are we really going
through this again like james gets fired
wants to come back like has to gravel
has to fix this has to say sorry and
then he gets to come back like
we've got to evolve yeah no i the max
and james story like i do hope that they
can rekindle their friendship because
max it seems like they've been friends
for a long time and max is a really good
friend to james yeah but like james
needs to be a better friend to max and
you can't just why is every time he gets
like angry and sees red he's calling
everyone fat yes katie what
max session with weight i thought the
exact same thing i don't know he's so
fat phobic like it makes me [ __ ] hate
him and i really do always like try and
like like yes he's getting two years
sober like i try and believe in him [ __ ]
that like seriously the obsession with
people's weight is insane yeah agreed
the other thing that we need to talk
about is just lala period everything all
of her arguments like she she's just so
here's what i love about lala she is so
above unapologetically herself that but
she's so above all of this like
in every way and yet she still comes and
she gets down in the mud and she's gonna
you know apologize for this or not
apologize for that not apologize for
that and i just i love her so much
always but even she was looking amazing
and her house is gorgeous she's just
everything of the sort and i'm so glad
she continues to grace us with her
presence because what would this she
doesn't have to you know and like she
like the fact that she's even engaging
in these conversations
yeah
i thank you lala i do like the one thing
i don't like about lala there's just one
thing okay
is that when she came on the show
and it's not really a thing anymore
because most of the cast mates are gone
but like when she came on the show she
was
bullied like
to another degree and the only girl who
was like really nice to her from day one
was sheena yeah
and then like when everyone realized
like lala was so cool and like she
started dating this movie producer and
she had this new car and she was just
like the coolest girl ever like one or
two seasons later everyone became best
friends with her
and she like she never left china behind
a hundred percent but maybe fifty
percent i don't think she hold on our
food's here oh our food's here should we
do a live unboxing again
okay i'll save my lala defense for when
i have your full attention
delicious
lunch
thank you
okay
so that's just i agree that that's what
it looks like you know she became part
of the cool crowd and then she like left
her friends who were there for her when
she first was new in school
but
i feel like she always was friends with
sheena and ariana too even as she was
friends with the witches of weho and
then for external reasons their
friendship started to slip not because
she forgot about where she came from
because if she did she wouldn't have
kept james kennedy with her for so long
well i do think that like she was like
somewhat like in love with james kennedy
for a short period of time maybe for
five days like maybe for a minute well i
just think we'll agree to disagree i
don't know how we can go on podcasting
when our food is here like i think we
have to wrap up yeah that plus that's
all i really wanted to say um next week
lala takes on charlie like and charlie
thinks she's like doing something and
i'm here to tell her she's not charlie
thinks she's lala and it's like there's
only one lala and you have to earn your
way there and you have to give them lala
yeah no and
lala just gave us so much before she
just
became someone that we just
rallied behind and we accept even though
sometimes she acts out of control yeah
but she also always
can see herself eventually you know
eventually yes yeah well that was the
vanderpump rules recap and we'll see how
many weeks we make it because it's
really not a great show yeah um but
speaking of
all
to me watching ratio it's directly
correlated that's such a good call so
we'll see
so that's our show you guys we hope you
have an amazing day thank you so much
for watching the morning toast
no thank you so much for seeing to the
morning toast millennial morning show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast and we're podcasting we found so
it's spotify itunes stitcher public
radio i ready to catch box all the
places so every listen to podcast find
out some more until sleep if i starve
you about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are
if you made to the end of the episode
congratulations you are a true listener
of this podcast and a member of the
society season two and to let us know
that you are true toaster who made it to
the end of the episode when you go to
our most recent instagram pic and drop
an emoji which emoji should we do today
the basketball
sure the basketball we're playing
let's get
bow
have a great day everyone we'll see you
tomorrow bye
we love that
bow